[Music]
the day after the elections and a
completely unforeseen outcome I think
for a lot of us in New York City we felt
like we're walking under this pall of
confusion and somberness and just trying
to make sense of what had just happened
and for me as a Muslim woman I
anticipated that I would have an
exceptionally hard day and yet I was so
surprised that the entire day was spent
with me receiving the warmest smiles
from people the kindest gestures more
people than normal amongst the rudest
people in the world New Yorkers holding
doors open for me or making a nice
comment to me like complimenting me on
my scarf or something like that
Antonia signifies that we all have this
common understanding that there are
people right now that are being targeted
and that we are all responsible for one
another and that we have to stand up for
each other and to me I took those little
moments with tiny exchanges as these
signifiers to me that I'm not alone and
we understand and we have your back and
you don't have to worry and like
actually get some emotional thinking
about it but it's even though they seem
like very inconsequential especially in
comparison to what could potentially be
happening on a much greater level right
now to me that's that's what hope is you
know it's in it's in the people and it's
in those interactions that we have with
one another especially for a person like
me that might feel more vulnerable or is
more susceptible to you know a lot of
hate these days those moments really are
the only thing that keeps me going it's
like okay I can face today I can like
get up in the morning and step out of my
house it's going to be okay and I'll
make it back tonight you know and I
don't think that people are aware of
just how much those little exchanges can
really mean to people or how much they
can completely turn around a person's
day and and honestly even in the midst
of everything that we're facing right
now and what the next few years could
potentially look like for us I still
have to optimistic based off of that
alone just because I know that I have
other people that are standing alongside
me and they're going to face this with
me together
[Music]